Ciao ragazzi bentornati a una nuova
puntata di "Cucina Buttata"
Oggi cercheremo di trasformare un oreo in un Oreo. Ora non so voi ma secondo me anche
in cucina le dimensioni contano. Perché
ho detto anche? Mmmm
Io ho voglia di mangiarmelo però mi serve come cavia per capire
anche questi geroglifici che dovrò piazzarci sopra
Chef Rico:"Ma se a telecamere spente ne hai fatti partire qualche otto!
No scusa possiamo far vedere? Che è la cappella Sistina? Ma una cosa più semplice?
Per fare un Oreo gigante avremo bisogno
intanto degli ingredienti per l'impasto
che sono: cioccolato amaro
farina
burro
ssughero
due uovi
e del sale
che non mi andava di far vedere sinceramente
Avremo
bisogno di una bella ciotola e un cucchiaio
una cucchiara de legna!
Io ringrazio "Pop Sugar" per avermi passato la ricetta
perché non avrei
saputo come proseguire altrimenti
Una cosa che è molto utile quando si fanno
delle ricette americane è quella di
avere a casa sempre i cosi per le misure
americane, perché in America non pesano
usano le tazze
Questi io li ho presi
tipo su Amazon,  non costano manco
troppo in realtà ragazzi, quindi
sinceramente vi suggerisco di comprarli
se anche voi volete rovinarvi la
giornata
Mettiamo una tazza e mezzo di farina
Chef Rico:"Ma la tazza e mezzo deve andare sul tavolo?"
Ma io non ho capito perchè loro
secondo me la farina ai supermercati la
chiudono in modo che nella piega ci sia
della farina che deve per forza cadere
Ok questa l'ho fatta cadere io
Uno
Shaka shaka shaka shaka shaka shaka shaka shaka
Mezzo. Ragazzi, pure questo qua, pazzesco!
Credo Ikea. Mai acquisto fu più utile
Poi aggiungiamo lo stesso quantitativo di
cioccolato. Ma siamo pazzi?
Si sente già l'odorino in questo quartiere una tazza eh?
Una tazza e
Chef Mario:"A dopo"
"A dopo, ciao amore". Con chi parlavi? Eh?
*versi di morte di Chef Rico*
Chef Mario:"Scusa mentre questo muore te lascio....
Senti. Chef Mario:"Ragazzi me devo fa un caffè al volo per favore. Chef Rico:"Dai fallo pure per me
Tranquillo fallo mentre cucino per me
non è un problema, non è un problema
Bastano?
Spero di si!
Aspetta dimenticavo un altro zucchero a velo hahaha  e......vanillina
E il burro? E il burro sempre di meno.
Volevi fa un chilo di burro?
Questa è la torta!
Ho capito che hai bisogno di un caffè
Fattelo tranquillamente mentre io cucino
Fai come se fossi a casa tua vai
Fuori dalla mia cucina!
*rumori assordanti della macchina del caffè"
Mettiamo anche un po di sale. Un
pizzichino giusto, per gradire
Ok. No questo era zucchero c***o!
C'è pure scritto!
Vabbé  non l'ho guardato
Sale ok...si effettivamente non sembrava sale
*rumore assordante della macchinetta del caffè*
Vabbè
Adesso iniziano ad arrivare i
problemi
Chef Mario:"No zi ho dato un calcio a...
Chef Rico:"No che c***o hai fatto?
Chef Mario:"Vie a vedé.Cioè è difficile che si sia sposato.
Esatto ha più fatto così capito?
Chef Rico:"Si continuiamo a..."
A muoverlo
Non avevo le fruste e quindi ho trovato questa frusta singola
Cioè non credo possa andar bene. A parte che non ci arriva
Ma è normale questo rumore secondo voi?
Chef Mario:"non gira benissimo"
Vabbè vediamo che succede
Du tazze due zucchero? Ma chi è che se magna du tazze de zucchero? Ma che è?
Ma come si fa a
fare una tazza di burro morbido?! E' un tetris
Secondo me ce ne vuole di più. Ma chi lo
mangia sopravvive?
Ok direi che può andare come tazza?! Vabbè andata!
Chef Rico:"Mamma mia!"
Chef Mario:"Secondo me stai esagerando col burro"
Secondo me tu invece stai esagerando con le tue parole
Chef Rico:"Ma poi non è morbido quel...
Tu non....un sercio
Allora proviamo a usare le fruste. O la va o la spacca
Spostiamoci, spostiamoci nella mia altra
cucina
Bisogna contrastare lo zucchero che cerca di uscire
*parole incomprensibili*
Aggiungiamo due uova
Uno
e...due
Aggiungiamo pian piano questa polvere
Ma intanto devono mischiar...
Mi raccomando delicati
Chef Rico:"Alza un attimo il cucchiaio
*risata Chef Rico*
Io...io adesso sto mescolando sterco. Cioè senza bisogno di girarci attorno
Aggiungiamo la restante parte. Cioè boh
Passiamo alle mani, secondo me sono le mani il trucco
Argilla nelle mani di uno scultore o m***a nelle mani di un coprofago
Verso il composto
Chef Rico:"Ma che stai facendo?"
Pierfra. Allora ti spiego. Cioè nel senso io...
ti giuro che te la lavo, però cioè, quale
cucina non si sporca quando cucini?
Cioè nel senso ma che cucina, che cucina hai?
Una cucina che non si sporca quando cucini?
Chef Rico:"Secondo me questa è diffamazione agli oreo
E' una grande pubblicità. Fai prima a comprarteli che a farli giganti
Chef Mario:"Con quello devi fare due  basi vero?"
Due basi più tutta la roba sopra ma non
ce la posso fare!
Chef Mario:"Di grandezza media forse viene"
Si non viene gigantesco
Chef Mario:"Quanto un biscotto oreo"
*risata Chef Rico*
Alla fine verrà cosi
Ok. Non ho più l'impronta per poter
sbloccare il mio telefono
*risate di sottofondo*
Certo! Lei con l'aiuto del coso. Grazie,
anch'io so bravo!
Chef Rico:"Si vede che sei totalmente...
Nel panico!
..... spaesato"
Si legge? Cioè si capisce che non so cosa
sto facendo?
Ho le mani sporche di m***a
E' un bel mattone. Tu calcola
che mangi questo e muori.
Questo qui è anche un potente veleno
Ma Ottavio dov'è quando serve?
Chef Rico:"Misa sta facendo dolci seri allora"
A cucinare roba...
vera?
Grazie mille
Non sarà gigantesco quest'oreo
Chef Rico:"Più che altro non sarà..."
buono
Ce l'ho ce l'ho
Un'altra carta forno
Sta finendo eh.
Ok, fine, basta così.  Proprio quanta ce ne serviva
Questa qui dobbiamo metterla in frigo un secondo e
poi ci dobbiamo fare le decorazioni
Mi dai una pellicola trasparente ti prego!
Grazie di cuore grazie vossignoria
Ok... bravo! Tieni te la regalo mettila in frigo
Pare un'altra cosa
Non lo dire!
Vabbè io prova a metterli tutti e due insieme?
Si sì questa c'ha molta più pasta rispetto a questa
però, se tu lo analizzi
in realtà, quello sopra è leggermente più piccolo
Ma perché c'è una bottiglia
d'acqua distillata in questo lavandino?
Intanto mettiamo questi qua tipo per una
quarantina di minuti all'interno del forno a 160 gradi
Ah ma non era caldo
ancora!
C'è un odore strano?
Chef Mario:"E' tipo di plastica bruciata
......
No ti prego! Com'è possibile?
....ah no scusate so queste. So le luci che odorano de plastica bruciata"
Ma v*******o!
Chef Rico:"Noi ci rifacciamo con l' odore dell'oreo
Poi guardi qua  aaaaaaaaaa
A questo punto direi di
continuare l'oreo.... facendo....mmm
*risata Chef Rico*
Perché ridi? Facciamo delle lettere
No,no. Ho sbagliato tutto!
Aspe' ma è partito  il forno?
ok...piazziamo
questo qui sopra
Chi sa da quanti soldi sarà questa bottiglia di Pierfra?
Chef Mario:"Non più tanto"
Chef Rico:"Ma perché non usi un mattarello?"
Perché non c'è!
E facciamo la o
Arricciamo
Or...
Chef Rico:"Orrido hahahha"
O-....re-....ndo
Secondo me quelli dell'oreo ci chiamano
in tribunale
Chef Rico:"Mamma mia!"
Ok sono grandi. A meno che non uso la
siringa di cioccolato per scrivere
In frigo si rapprenderà tutto
Passiamo
questo punto all'interno del mega Oreo
Quindi, per fare il feeling servirà
zucchero a velo a manetta
burro a manetta
della vanillina perché non ho
trovato l'estratto di vaniglia quindi ce
la facciamo andare bene e.... del latte.
In
realtà due cucchiai di latte, vabbè questo buono per la colazione domani
Per
prima cosa dobbiamo montare...il burro di nuovo
Io c'ho sempre sto problema della
tazza di burro. Eh ma non è ancora una tazza
Vabbè, una tazza di burro
Passiamo alla mia
cucina secondaria
Si sta schierando una piramide
E a questo punto dobbiamo
aggiungere lo zucchero.
Quattro, quattro di questi
Allora aggiungiamo un po di vanillina....
una busta
Io vedo che schizzano le cose, schizzano
nel cielo
Quattro.. tazze di zucchero a velo
Allora
Chef Mario:"Pesante questa roba messa tutta insieme
Questa ricetta è veramente tanto tanto
tanto tanto impegnativa
Prima tazza. Andiamo a sbattere
Secondo me è uscito tutto
Ok.... siamo a un'altra tazza
Shaka shaka shaka shaka shaka shaka
Si sta rompendo
non riesce più a resistere allo stress
Vabbè andiamo avanti nonostante tutto,
non ce ne frega niente dai
Shaka shaka shaka
Lo
aggiusteremo
Aggiungiamo un'altra tazza di zucchero
Ma sbaglio o
ne perdiamo metà ogni volta che dobbiamo farla sta cosa?
Ecco perché quattro buste
davvero
Un'altra tazza di zucchero
Shakalaka shakalaka lakalaka lakalalakalaka lakalaka
Chaka chaka chaka
Ah bisogna aggiungere due cucchiaini di latte
Uno...due
Ok questo era l'ultimo di zucchero
Chef Rico:"Di che sa?...........
E' terribile?"
E' come infilare la testa nelle tue analisi del sangue
Ok. Non lo vedi che.... l'angolino?
E' normale in questo momento provare...
questa sensazione, si chiama salivazione
Ok prima di tutto non dobbiamo arrenderci!
secondo
dobbiamo creare il ripieno all'interno
Ooo.Uuu. Che strana consistenza!
Sta
roba in frigo....ok
E' arrivato il momento di comporre il nostro oreo
Questo si sta
spappolando
Questo.... sopra
poi.... questo
Avrei dovuto fare anche le lettere
Troppo tardi
Ok.... questo
qui
questo..... qui
questo
qui
e qui
Striscetta
Lasciamolo stare proprio quell'oreo che
non c'entra niente
Ok. Mostruoso! Mostruoso!
E per
fortuna non si mangia con gli occhi
Però ricordiamo sempre con cosa si c**a
Gli diamo
un po di decorate ok? C'è la buttiamo in caciara
Sembra Stonehenge
Ok io
purtroppo non avevo la, le lettere perché
non c'entravano quindi ho messo dei
simboli pagani all'interno di questo biscotto
però quello che potete vedere è
che
Dio ti prego ....è un oreo..... gigante
Ci sta. Ora la mia domanda è chi se la sente di dargli un morso?
Allora... è buonissimo ma io fino al 2020 dopo sto morso
sto a posto
Questo è l'importo calorico di cui
ha bisogno
una persona nel giro di dieci anni
Cioè se tuo figlio nasce e lo lasci da solo
nella culla con questo
dà l'ultimo boccone che diciotto anni e la patente che ha 18 anni e la patente
Comunque ragazzi questa era la ricetta dell'Oreo gigante
Fatemi sapere se volete farlo anche voi
se vi capita taggatemi sulle vostre
stories, sulle vostre foto
Se posso darvi un consiglio non provatela  casa,
non la fate mai più!
Noi ci vediamo naturalmente la prossima domenica con
un'altra puntata di" Cucina Buttata"
Ciao
Ora mi faccio quasì uno shottino di
questo per, capito? Mandarla giù
*risata Chef Rico*
Vai!
Ma in un boccone?
No Enrico...ma ce l'abbiamo un defibrillatore?
E' importante!
E' importante eh!
Se ora stai avendo delle visioni è normale
Mi faccio uno shottino anche io
Si Giammi tu,  che a te che te non
piacciono i dolci vomiti. Preparati a vomitare
Un boccone ogni dieci anni si può fare
Mettilo nel frigo al  Purci(cugino)
Aspetta che avevo bisogno di qualcosa di salato